tout les gens
pendant la question à se poser est la
suivante est ce que l'homme fait partie
d'un cycle naturel dans lequel il est un
prédateur et les animaux sont habitués à
voir des prédateurs et l'homme fait
partie de ce cycle une chasse il tue un
autre animal qui pourrait très bien tué
par autre chose que l'homme ou est-ce
que l'homme sort de ce cadre du cycle
naturel il est extérieur et donc qu'est
ce qui se passe si l'extérieur ce que je
crois c'est que ce cycle naturel que
personnellement j'aimais bien où
effectivement on trouve des gens très
proches de la nature qui connaissent les
animaux les espèces etc je l'aimé bien
mais je crois qu'il est effectivement en
train de s'évanouir et qu'on est passé à
une sorte d'industrialisation à une
technologie passion de la chasse est en
fait moi je fais partie des gens qui
adorent changé d'avis je suis à deux
doigts de le faire quand j'entends les
arguments 1954 en fait qu'ils reviennent
c'est toujours les mêmes choses qui sont
en bas n'ont pas défendu mais presque
roter et donc une certaine manière non
parce que j'avais vraiment des arguments
et je dois vous dire ce soir une chose
c'est que les arguments les plus
intelligents sur dans le camp adverse et
effectivement
il ya des noms qui se passe quelque
chose initialement si je passe quelques
chants des changes et elsa mais que vous
le vouliez ou non que voulez-vous les
noms ils ont raison c'est une chose
l'argument intelligents ils ont donné
parce que si vous couper la parole sans
cesse il ne réside pas dans des abîmes
intelligent et minutieusement cessé de
d'interrompre les jeux les gens de
manière bête il vous aura peut-être des
réponses intelligentes alors allez-y la
chose à la suivante effectivement il ya
quelque chose qui a évolué en ce début
de 21e siècle c'est la perception que
nous avons des animaux ce ne sont plus
des bêtes ce sont des animaux et les
animaux ont peut-être qui sait des
droits ils sont peut-être pas égaux aux
hommes ils ont peut-être un univers tout
à fait étrange à l'homme
l'anthropomorphisme n'est pas une
solution le fait d'avoir l'ennemi comme
animal n'en est pas une mais peut-être
que l'animal vit dans un cosmos à parme
où il est ni plus intelligent ni moins
intelligents que nous mais il conserve
un mystère et ce mystère que vous le
vouliez ou non monsieur il vous
échappera et les arguments que vous
donnez tout à l'heure en disant qu'est
ce que vous en savez qu'un renard
souffre au moins extra peu importe
l'idée c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya un
saccage de la nature il ya une violence
faite à la nature la perception de
l'animal est en train d'évoluer et je
crois heureusement que certains
individus se rapproche des bêtes mais
pas dans le sens où il le voudrait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en
amont des magazines aujourd'hui their de
savoir est ce que les animaux regarde
balance contrat
[Applaudissements]
social supérieur monsieur peyras il faut
répondre à tout d'abord les accidents de
chasse les chiffres sont donnés quand
même un peu inquiétant nous la pollution
et le changement de statut de l'annuel
voilà alors alors d'abord sur la
question des sur la question des
accidents où nous sommes passés d'une
situation où il y avait une centaine
d'accidents mortels par an à l'année
d'avant aux accidents dont
pour revenir sur dix et il a donc une
seule personne qui n'était pas chasseur
une seule personne est là c'est bien
alors si on compte tous les pratiquants
on en revient sur l'exode sur ce qui été
dit tout à l'heure et on dit telle
activité je ne veux pas incité génère
tant d'accidents par hommes sont-ils
interdire la mission chasse à l'orignal
amer
gilenya la même ambiance ils me rendent
d'habitude c'est l'amour et lumineux
imaginé qu en tant que juge compétent
sur le seul match de tennis quand on
joue une balle ça tue un spectateur on
arrêterait le ténu et c'est ce que nous
ferons